if I'm honest one of the reasons I sold
to Adobe is because they were so
aggressive about competing in the space
I think you Dobie brand I'm indigenous
they give you a million dollars but some
of it was it was a it was a bear hug
with a lot of threats and if you don't
sell we're gonna buy your competitor
really and when you hear that and that's
just part of M&A incorporated but you
can't take this stuff too seriously even
if it's true and I'm sure it was true
but you're like oh my god I mean these
guys have an 800 million dollar
franchise and they have every customer
and they have the brand and yeah I have
a lot of customers but people are gonna
trust there but how does a big company
communicate that to a little startup
without pissing off the founder like
because for some founders in there by
definition of founder is going to be a
rabble rouser rebel fighter yeah so if
you tell a fighter
hey listen sell or we're gonna kick your
ass yes that's like poking a tiger I
mean they just literally might swing at
you my limit Mike spirit my own
experience but then when I've talked to
other founders it's usually the same
stick and what it is you can approach
you know and they say well we're think
Jason we're thinking about doing a build
by a partner decision uh-huh build by a
partner and in a way no one wants to
make an offer and have it slapped away
there's a lot a there's a lot of not
just ego issues and make companies but
there's structural issues a VP or an SVP
doesn't want to put a deal on the line
and then not close the deal right take
on the face yeah so they're gonna tell
you build buyer partner even if the only
thing they're looking for is buy right
huh is it out we're looking at build by
a partner what would you like to partner
with us but in all discourage we might
build it ourselves
but we haven't started yet or we might
even buy something in the space and
they'll look and see if you lean forward
or what the body language is and they'll
know right little bit of a poker game a
little bit of a poker game and everyone
starts with the bill buy or a partner
that that's just like I think that's in
corporate development 101 in the book
they that you can buy on Amazon
somewhere build on it and so it always
starts there and then usually the threat
comes along when there's interest in the
buy but not fall over out of the table
interest right or or people they get
that you know I don't really need to do
this and because it deals who doesn't
need to do it the target the sorta right
it also all starts up nice yeah and then
sometimes you realize when you get into
it that
I don't know like I don't need to do
this yeah we had like we have money in
the bank we're doing 10 million 20
million we're profitable yeah I think
then the kind of the threat side comes
out in almost every deal it's and how do
they communicate the threat well they
just they're honest and they they'll say
when they see you awfully and they'll
say listen if you don't want to do this
it's okay we understand
oh so that's nice yeah you're nice but
you let you know we'll buy the next guy
in the list hmm and there's fraud a
threat that's not a threat it's reality
it's reality right yeah and even if it's
not reality it's close enough to reality
and it may become reality if when a
company decides they want to enter a
space right they really enter it for and
they want to buy they want to accelerate
time and they want to accelerate
traction right so they either do one of
two things either either they'll buy any
vendor but they want to buy the best one
that matches their needs or there's
really only one that they want and you
have to understand and sometimes there
really is only one solution but other
times you'll turn around and if they
believe they can push a product through
their channel then they'll do number two
number three or number four even if
maybe they shouldn't because they
believe they're they're wonderful sales
team or their brand or whatever can can
push it through the channel so you have
to know it's hard to know yeah and if
you look at a lot of M&A and you're like
well why did why did Salesforce or
Google or Facebook by this company
sometimes sometimes it was really the
second choice right you didn't really
see that what happened for the first
person ad right and and and were it's
more common and what I learned is
there's two types of M&A there's CEO
level M&A and SVP level M&A Oh explain
when I'm Mark Zuckerberg and I want to
win I'm gonna give 10% of my company
known whatsapp leave me alone I don't
want your opinion I don't care what the
board says he did that 10% he'd even go
to the board we share didn't care
didn't care or for Instagram you know
why because I know this is the winner
and I know if I give 10% of my shares to
whatsapp my shares will be worth more
than 10% accretive it's a no-brainer for
a founder I get anything above board
thought this was insane 20-something
billion by the time the deal closed as a
founder so she knows and so CEOs almost
always know the exact target they want
it maybe they're well maybe maybe maybe
oculus was the wrong choice but it was
clear that's the one he wanted yeah
right unproven not launched 22 year old
founder but
the one I want SVP driven deals are less
about the five and 10-year future of the
company which is what CEO divs and it's
more about making my plan it's more
about making my plan I'm behind on weba
fication I'm a plot I'm behind on this
initiative
when SVP needs to close a deal this year
because I'm gonna miss the plan he wants
to hit the target it's the target yeah
right and they have a budget [ __ ]
away it's self-preservation SVP VP level
deals
it looks like it's it's positive but
it's really generally to fill a hole a
gap that's missing
which isn't necessarily a bad thing it's
not a bad thing it drives a lot of it
drives a lot of nine and eight figure
M&A is filling a hole and you have a
budget and you have a chip and but a VP
level when a VP level deal happens they
have their there they're number one
target in a space and this is the one
they want and sometimes it's not
rational the reason they take it may be
because they're the ones that are in
TechCrunch it may be because the one
that's prettier but this is the vendor I
want but if they don't get number one
you know what they're gonna do they're
gonna you're gonna go to number two and
then they're gonna go to number three
they got to get a deal done yeah